you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme
as the first ever extreme heat warning
is issued in the uk we look at how
climate change is affecting temperatures
us climate envoy john kerry visits the
uk saying there's an urgent need for
global climate action
and find out what impact your pint has
on the climate
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes
happening to our world right now and
meet those coming up with
solutions well we're starting today at
our data dashboard because our planet
is heating up the world is now just over
1.2 degrees warmer than it was before
the industrial revolution and that's
having an impact on our weather
causing more frequent and intense
droughts wildfires
storms and rainfall the devastating
flooding in parts of europe last week
has already been blamed by
some on climate change and now here in
the uk the met office has issued its
first ever extreme heat warning
well the top 10 warmest years for the uk
since 1884 have
all occurred since 2002. 2019 alone
broke
four records including the warmest
winter day on record
and the warmest easter day let's remind
you of the hottest temperatures
recorded in each part of the uk in
england cambridge botanic gardens hit
38.7 degrees in july 2019
the record high in wales was 35.2
degrees in 1990.
scotland hit nearly 33 degrees in august
2003
and a record temperature was set in
northern ireland this weekend with bali
wattycock in county down
reaching 31.2 degrees celsius
while extreme summer temperatures are
now 30 times more likely
than in pre-industrial times the latest
met office projections of future uk
climate change suggests summer
temperatures now classed as heat waves
could be the norm by the 2050s which is
the context
to the new extreme heat warning and it's
issued to highlight
potential widespread disruption and
adverse
health effects it means changes to
working practice
says might be needed heat sensitive
systems and equipments
could fail transport could be disrupted
and more people
are more likely to visit coastal areas
and rivers and lakes which leads to a
risk
of water safety incidents well our
science correspondent thomas moore
is in south oxford forest thomas is the
uk prepared for this
in a word no jane i think the problem is
that uh people just aren't aware enough
of what he can do
two and a half thousand people died last
summer as a direct consequence of heat
and that is likely to increase
with climate change and the government
has a heatwave plan but the problem is
that the alert system isn't being
triggered early enough
many people are ending up in hospital
and even dying without the
an alert going out now part of that is
about behavior changing here at south
oxford bowles club they've just taken a
break in the shade some cold drinks
but it's also about starting work
earlier in the day when it's cooler
but primarily it is about housing and 20
percent of people
live in houses that overheat and they
can get no
relief from these high temperatures and
that is a fundamental problem with the
design of our buildings
at the moment there is also the
infrastructure railways buckle
uh under the the heat bridges too and
this is a problem that needs to be
resolved because as i say
climate is only going to get worse
thomas
thanks very much
well let's bring in alex deakin
meteorologist at the met office
alex can you explain why these heat
warnings might become more frequent
well climate change is the simple answer
to that
the climate is warming up we know that
across the planets but
also across the uk we've seen that
because we've got
very detailed information going back
well over 100 years
in some instances several hundred years
of the temperature
in the uk we can see it's it's been
rising and it's more likely
over the next few years few decades that
we're going to see more
extremes all the computer models suggest
that and
not only are we just seeing a shift so
the average temperature is increased we
are just seeing more frequent episodes
of these extreme temperatures so we're
only going to see more of them in the
future
and the peak of the extreme is also
likely to rise so when we see the top
end of the extreme it's likely just to
get pushed pushed
further and further so more records will
be broken i mean theoretically how hot
could it get
well that's a that's a tricky one to
answer obviously the uk is an island
surrounded by uh cooling
seas and it's not really a question
about how hot it's going to get in terms
of you know compared to other places
around the planet it's what we can cope
with in this country and it's about
managing expectations and
getting the infrastructure right so that
we can cope with the rising temperatures
we are expected to see extremes be
pushed and pushed further and further
but it's more about that kind of
just general seeing more of these
extreme weather events so it's not just
about the temperatures it's about more
extreme rainfall
as well so we're more likely to see
flooding it's all about the extremes
and the ability for uh the uk in
particular to cope
what about those alex who will just say
well this is just the weather i remember
hot summers from my childhood
well the answer to that is they're
simply becoming more and more frequent
and we've got all the statistics uh
to back that up for example 2018 the
joint hottest summer on record joint
with 1976
people do often remember that one and
cite that one but that was followed
uh by 2019 where we saw the highest
temperature ever recorded in the uk and
then
2020 which is the third warmest year on
record
uh in a series going back well over 100
years the statistics
are clear everything is pointing to the
fact that things are getting hotter and
we're seeing more
and more of these extreme events all the
computer models suggest
that uh by 2050 the summer of 2018 will
be
a one in two year event so it'll be a
fairly typical
summer and that was as i say the joint
hottest on record overall
alex deacon thanks very much
well in today's other climate news the
government is being urged to create
100 000 hectares of wetlands in the uk
to help combat the climate crisis the
wildfowl and wetlands trust
says that wetlands are vital as they
store carbon reduce flooding
and help biodiversity new research by
the charity found that more than three
quarters of people in britain think that
there should be more investment
in natural solutions
the international energy agency is
warning that global emissions
are set to soar as economies recover
from the pandemic
the agency estimates governments around
the world have only allocated
two percent of their recovery fund to
clean energy measures
it says global clean energy investments
need to increase by around two thirds to
prevent emissions reaching record levels
by 2023
and a mini golf course has opened in new
york city which aims to teach players
about climate change
local artists and non-profit groups have
designed the 18 holes at
putting green to highlight environmental
issues and solutions
players can find out more about wind
energy emissions and the effects of
melting ice caps by
reading information on placards whilst
they putt
to the u.s now where officials in oregon
are asking for help to contain a massive
wildfire in the state the bootleg fire
has grown to 537
square miles due to gusty winds and dry
hot weather which is expected to
continue over the coming days
it's one of more than 80 wildfires to
have broken out across
the western united states forcing
thousands to flee their homes
scientists say climate change has made
the west much warmer and drier
and will continue to make weather more
extreme and wildfires
more frequent well this comes as there
are just over 100 days to go
until the most important climate summit
in years cop26
the conference will be held in glasgow
in november bringing together heads of
state
business leaders scientists and
campaigners and ahead of the meeting the
u.s climate envoy john kerry
is in the uk earlier he visited kew
gardens in london
and spoke about the urgent need for
global climate action
even if everyone did what they said they
would do in paris
the temperature of this planet will
still rise
by upwards of 2.5 or 3 degrees
centigrade we're already seeing dramatic
consequences
with 1.2 degrees imagine the doubling
to contemplate doubling that is to
invite catastrophe
our climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter was listening to that speech and
has the latest
that was as strong a speech as i've
heard from special envoy
john kerry on the subject of climate
change a speech that sounded like it was
being
fueled by something approaching anger
definitely frustration
that we are now in the defining decade
of action when it comes to international
consensus
and commitments to reduce carbon
emissions and that we have no
alternative but to get this right
because he painted a very scary picture
of an increasingly
unlivable unstable world if it continues
to warm he called climate change the
test of our time
an acute and as existential test
as any previous one and he labored the
point that no country
rich or poor will be spared and then
spoke
about the extreme weather that we have
been seeing
in western europe in terms of the floods
and in america
in terms of the heat and it's
interesting because climate scientists
themselves are getting more and more
confident about how closely they can
link climate change to these individual
extreme events
we've just spoken to nasa's senior
climate advisor
gavin schmidt and this is what he had to
say
when we've seen situations like in the
pacific northwest which
blew through the records in such a
dramatic fashion uh you're looking at
ratios
like 150 times maybe a thousand times
more likely to happen now than it would
have done at which point you can start
to say well it would never have happened
before
and so you can basically say that this
event
is uh almost 100 attributable
to the fact that the climate has changed
when you start to hear messages like
that from nasa when you start to hear
speeches like that from john kerry
you've got a sense
of the momentum at the urgency around
this
issue of increased commitments to reduce
carbon emissions
because as john kerry said it is without
exaggeration
now about survival all eyes on that
crucial climate meeting cop 26 being
hosted by the brits in glasgow
in november emissions from the food and
drinks sector need to be cut in half by
the end of the decade according to the
environmental charity
rap and while there's been lots of focus
on how what we eat affects the
environment
we don't talk as much about the climate
impact of what we drink
so here's your 60 second guide to how
green your evening pint
really is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's all from us for today next time
how small changes to how we build our
homes can make a big difference
in keeping them cool we could all do
with that you can find out more tomorrow
at the same time here on the daily
climate show
[Music]